All right.
So far we've seen a lot of
short statements defining and
manipulating data types and
data structures.
Now it's time for control flow,
the syntax of telling your program
which statements to execute when.
For this module you want to be
following along in the playground file
entitled l four control flow.
Let's start with for loops.
Swift supports traditional C style for
loops like this one.
Note that there are no
parentheses around the condition.
If you're used to C style languages, you
might miss the parentheses at first but
they'll soon fade from your heart and
you'll realize you're
better off without them.
C style for
loops might work well for bar songs.
But I think you'll really come to
appreciate the efficiency of Swift's
fast enumeration with for-in loops,
which you've got a glimpse of earlier
when we talked about in strings.
For-in loops take the general form,
for item in Collection.
And then between curly braces,
the statements you want to execute
on each item in the collection.
To iterate through this string for
example, we just write for
character in demostring.characters,
which is a collection of characters.
And then this print statement
will be executed on every item in
the collection.
In this case,
every character in the string.
It's super convenient.
And then,
here's what it prints to the console.
Let's see another example.
Let's find the sum of all
the ints in this array.
To do that, we just type for
value in intArray.
And this statement adding it to
the sum will be executed for
each member of the collection.
You can see here in the playground
sidebar that it's being
executed five times.
And then if we want to see our sum,
we can just type some and
that will appear in
the playground sidebar as well.
We can use for-in to iterate
through dictionaries as well.
Here we have a dictionary of movies and
their directors.
And here's a for loop that prints
out a statement about who directed
each of the movies in movie dict.
You can see that the syntax is similar
to iterate it through an array.
In this case the key value pair is
placed in parentheses after for.
And then both key and value can be
referred to in the body of the loop.
And if we want to see that
output in the console,
we just go down to
the bottom of the screen and
click on this button that shows
the rectangle with the triangle inside.
And here's the output we're looking for.
But for the most part we're going to
stick to looking at our results in
the playground sidebar.
So let's close the console for now.
Let's do one more.
Let's try something with
the animal group's dictionary.
Here the plural animal name is the key
and the animal group name is the value.
And we can iterate through each pair to
print out a statement about each group.
So if we open up the console again,
we can see that many whales form a pod,
many lions form a pride,
many geese form a flock.
What do many auditions form?